[Musique]
les élus du département se sont réunis
ce lundi 25 juin dans l'hémicycle du
palais de la source pour une séance
plénière exceptionnelle
ils ont débattu sur le contrat de
confiance est à département de
programmation des finances publiques
2018 2022 la séance a débuté par un
hommage à paul est à douala katia
conseillère départementale du port
décédé le 14 juin dernier après cet
hommage les élus sont passés à l'étude
du contrat de confiance
j'ai réussi à faire prendre conscience
refait de la réunion mais surtout aux
instances parisiennes ministériel que
nous sommes dans une situation difficile
ici à la réunion avec un taux de chômage
élevé à tout pauvreté élevés un
environnement un environnement
géopolitique qui nous contraint qui nous
impose des efforts supplémentaires par
rapport aux départements de métropole et
ses arguments ont été entendus
on ne peut pas demander au département
de la réunion avec tout
tous les désavantages que nous avons à
tous les efforts que nous demande on
peut pas demander ces mêmes efforts
département la réunion au département de
métropole les dispositifs prévoit la
limitation d'évolution des dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités à 1,2
pour cent par an après de dures
négociations menées avec le préfet le
président du département obtenu un taux
de 1 32% annuel entre 2017 et 2020 ça
change tout ça laisse des marges de
manoeuvre dans le cadre d'abord de ce
que le département faisait en action
sociale ça ne les touche pas et ça
permet même au cas où il ya des
situations encore plus importante de
pouvoir inventer de nouveaux dispositifs
pour accompagner les enfants pas
accompagné maman pour accompagner les
personnes âgées pour accompagner les
gens qui sont différents de la vie les
handicapés donc c'est un grand pas sans
ce grande pas le département aurait été
presque en arrêt de finances dire que
tôt ou tard si nous n'avions pas obtenu
c'était la femme du département de la
réunion
comme entité comme outil comme acteurs
de l'accompagnement du social à la
réunion
deux motions ont ensuite été présentés
dont une adopté à l'unanimité pour le
maintien des fonds européen agricole
[Musique]